[Applaudissements]
c'est quand on vit un match avec daniel
narcisse tous se rencontrent du chemin
accompli depuis la réunion
à 39 ans il termine par un titre de
champion de france avec le psg en balles
pendant ce temps en toute discrétion
dans le salon vip
le club a fait venir la famille de
daniel un beau moment de partage pour
couronner 20 ans de professionnalisme 20
ans loin de sa famille
on voulait lui faire une surprise donc
je sais pas comment ça va se passer à la
fin mais pour nous c'est déjà son
exemple il a pu vivre pleinement sa
passion et
encore plus heureux de pouvoir partager
cette dernière attend avec ça va ça va
lui permettre aussi de peut-être voir
plus de sa famille et ça c'est que
tubulaire pour nous aussi
malgré un match disputé contre chambéry
la 50e minute et l'aura de daniel font
de ce moment une apothéose le protocole
est organisé mais l'émotion est
insoutenable au sport français c'est son
humanité ses qualités physiques cesse
son côté décisif c'est énormément de
choses sur son bonheur à chaque fois
qu'il est qu'il était sur le terrain
cette envie de voir la ddc ses
coéquipiers honnêtement ça a été une
énorme fierté et un bonheur dieu de
pouvoir le trottoir et aussi longtemps j
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait quoi si ça fait quoi là c'est
compliqué puisque beaucoup d'émotions
partagées
la peur parce que dans ce match assez
compliqué
ça joue aujourd'hui
son macho mais après je vais fermer
parce que c'est pas tout dans la lâcher
même
version rémois exténuant sur son terrain
tout le monde a
un te donner pour les salles cherche à
sortir ce soir là beaucoup de cadres de
ce club majeurs sont sur le départ
une nouvelle page s'ouvre daniel entre
maintenant dans le staff du psg handball
ce modèle pour la jeunesse compte bien
continuer à briller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]